j'ouvre notre second débat tout de suite
débats de société consacrée ce soir à
cette acronyme ces trois lettres
ZFE pour zone à faible d'émission l'idée
c'est d'interdire les centres-villes aux
véhicules les plus polluants quelle
voiture sont et seront concernées avant
de débattre de cette mesure qui
contestée par certains élus Jonathan
dupiez nous explique ce dispositif de
restriction de la circulation
ZFE ou zone affaiblissement derrière
cette acronyme un dispositif qui
ambitionne d'améliorer la qualité de
l'air dans les grandes villes 11
agglomérations en France ont déjà mis en
place ce type de dispositif Paris Lyon
Aix-Marseille Grenoble ou encore Nice
ces villes peuvent restreindre la
circulation des véhicules les plus
polluants et les interdire à terme d'ici
à 2025 la France comptera 43 ZF dans des
agglomérations de plus de 150 000
habitants une fois lasé des feux créés
les collectivités territoriales décident
du périmètre et des dérogations
possibles mais doivent respecter un
calendrier progressif d'interdictions de
circulation si les normes de qualité de
l'air fixées au niveau européen sont
dépassés la qualité de l'air la
protection de la santé des Français on
ne transige pas avec en parallèle on le
fait pas n'importe comment on rétablit
pas des péages à l'entrée des villes on
construit un dispositif national chaque
ville aura ensuite à le mettre en place
à déterminer les amplitudes les horaires
et en parallèle
en aide les Français qui sont concernés
par les plus vieux véhicules à en
acquérir de nouveaux un calendrier
national de restriction de circulation
des automobiles est prévue pour les
villes qui dépassent les seuils
européens de qualité de l'air critères 5
en 2023 critères 4 en 2024 et critères 3
en 2025 l'idée de ces zones
affaiblissement est apparue en 2019 puis
voter en 2021 dans la loi climat et
résilience la pollution atmosphérique
est responsable de 40 000 décès chaque
année en France
les zones à faible émission voilà le
thème de notre débat avec Mireille
chirolu Assouline bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes économie spécialiste de
l'environnement professeur à la Paris
School of économique et à l'Université
Paris Panthéon Sorbonne de
jacqueuillaume gonta bonsoir bienvenue à
vous vous êtes sénateurs de l'Isère
président du groupe écologiste au Sénat
Fabrice Godefroy bonsoir bienvenue à
vous expert mobilité environnement à
l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes Laetitia cruppa
évidemment est resté à mes côtés
peut-être un tour de table tiens pour
pour commencer il faut savoir si vous
êtes favorable ou pas à ces zones à
faible émission miry-sur-lignon je
commence avec vous les zones
affaiblissions sont un instrument
absolument indispensable quand on voit
le niveau de la pollution atmosphérique
dans les villes en France et le fait que
la France a été sanctionné à plusieurs
reprises par l'Europe puis par le
Conseil d'État parce que elle met la
santé des habitants des villes en danger
en laissant cette pollution à un tel
niveau
les zones affaiblission sont un moyen de
limiter la circulation des véhicules les
plus pollants Guillaume Gontard
j'imagine que vous y êtes favorable
pourquoi ouais je pense que d'abord ce
qui vient d'être dit je pense que c'est
à la fois indispensable c'est un enjeu
un enjeu sanitaire la question de la
pollution de la pollution de l'air on
sait que c'est entre 50 et 100000 décès
prématurés par an et donc on a vraiment
cette enjol là si je rappelle et que je
fais une comparaison c'est l'équivalent
de ce que notamment de l'alcool du tabac
mais c'est aussi le covid c'était ça a
été sur la totalité de la période 150
000 décès donc quand on ramène ces
chiffres là oui on voit qu'il y a un
enjeu sanitaire fort mais aussi qu'on
sait qu'on a des moyens d'action la ZFE
en fait partie comment on agit au niveau
des territoires dans les dans les villes
et donc avec un certain nombre de
dispositifs mais forcément quand il
s'agit de changer d'habitude de changer
de comportement de modifier des
comportements pour notre bien à tous
c'est jamais simple et donc ça
s'accompagne et ça ça demande un certain
nombre de concertation et de dialogue
évidemment les mesures d'accompagnement
c'est centrales et ça prendra une part
importante à notre débat Fabrice gotfr
votre avis
alors évidemment tout le monde a
conscience qu'évidemment il faut
améliorer la qualité de l'air c'est déjà
le cas d'une façon naturelle la qualité
de l'air s'améliore chaque année quand
même régulièrement notamment à Paris
c'est les rapports d'air Paris qui le
montrent par exemple
ça c'est une première chose et la
deuxième chose les zones de familles
mission c'est quoi c'est une c'est une
interdiction c'est une véritable
obsolescence programmée quand on est en
train de mettre en fait sur l'automobile
c'est à dire qu'en fait on est en train
de mettre de date de péremption sur les
cartes grises des automobilistes quand
ils ont acheté la voiture ils ne
savaient pas que la carte grise avait
s'autodétruire et donc on peut même se
poser la question de savoir si une
obsolescence programmée quand on sait
qu'il y a des lois antigashi
anti-obsolescence programmée et on le
fait sur l'automobile donc c'est vrai
qu'on peut même se poser
des voitures donc en fin voilà en
dépensant de la matière mobilisant oui
en créant finalement de un bilan CO2
autour de ces voitures pour les jeter
dans quelques dans quelques années c'est
exactement ça oui quand on parle de la
vie étroit les laisser aller au bout de
leur vie bah en fait on a un contrôle
technique qui a été renforcé sur la
pollution en 2019 donc déjà les
véhicules les plus polluants sont sortis
par le contrôle technique d'ailleurs on
devait avoir un contrôle technique
renforcé sur les oxydes d'azote qui
n'est pas encore arrivé donc ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose à traiter pour
effectivement éliminer du parc roulant
les véhicules les plus polluants mais en
ce qui concerne les véhicules évidemment
le parc roulant doit se renouveler d'une
façon naturelle on a déjà un cap qui a
été fixé par l'Europe de la fin du
moteur thermique en 2035 tous les
constructeurs sont en train de se
mobiliser justement pour électrifier les
véhicules et avoir les véhicules de
moins en moins pollants d'obliger les
automobilistes de mettre à la poubelle
leur voiture pour en refabriquer des
nouvelles qui quelques façons fabriquées
en Chine avec de l'électricité charbon
je trouve ça effectivement extrêmement
avis aussi Laetitia puis ensuite on va
développer les le thème qui ont été
abordés
après mais si oui mais oui mais
il faut d'abord informer les Français je
ne sais pas combien de français savent
parce que
on est là pour ça on est là pour ça il
faut les informer mais le gouvernement
doit faire une grande campagne
d'information pour comprendre que c'est
ce n'est pas forcément une injustice
pour les plus pauvres les couches
défavorisées de la population et surtout
surtout il faut proposer des
alternatives c'est à dire que si on dit
à un teleste ta voiture il faut qu'on
lui propose
alors puisqu'on doit faire un peu de
pédagogie je vous donne la carte des 11
villes enfin on va pas voir seulement
voir les 11 vidéos il y a 11 villes en
France qui ont déjà institué une zone
affaiblissement vous allez les voir
apparaître sur sur cette carte je crois
qu'elles sont en bleu sur la carte si je
ne me trompe c'est ça donc je vais pas
toutes les citer ex Grenoble Lyon Nice
Paris Rouen Strasbourg Toul et Toulouse
et d'ailleurs on sera en reportage à
Toulouse pour voir comment ça ça
fonctionne là-bas mais alors ce qui est
intéressant sur cette carte c'est qu'on
voit aussi que d'ici janvier 2025 il y
aura 43 métropoles de plus de 150 000
habitants qui vont interdire aux
véhicules portant des vignettes critères
et là c'est très précis si vous avez une
voiture vous savez de quoi on parle
qu'une vignette critères 3 4 et 5
interdite de centre-ville voilà ce qui
est prévu à partir de 2025 dans 43
métropoles ça représente 14 millions de
véhicules on parle quoi on parle je
reste avec vous rapidement on parle des
vieux diesel notamment c'est alors trois
quatre et cinq c'est tous les diesel
avant 2011 et tous les essences avant
2006 aujourd'hui c'est à peu près 48% du
parc roulant mais ça c'est qu'une étape
je rappelle quand même que le Grand
Paris avait un calendrier extrêmement
ambitieux qui était valait au-delà il
devait éliminer la vignette critère 2
comme à Paris d'ailleurs qui a été
annoncé donc c'est-à-dire tous les
diesels et tous les essences avant 2011
et ça c'était en 2024 parce que c'est
impossible justement alors totalement on
a bien entendu vos arguments je voulais
savoir quelle voiture était concernée
par ces critères ces vignettes 3 4 et 5
Guillaume Gontard il y a effectivement
l'argument allaitia a commencé à
l'aborder l'argument
social d'une certaine façon c'est à dire
que est-ce qu'on est en train de bannir
des centres-villes des Français qui ont
pas les moyens de s'acheter une voiture
électrique ou trouver une autre option
il faut il faut justement que ce ne soit
pas ça ça veut dire que évidemment comme
ça évidemment il y a une vraie question
sociale et c'est comment justement on
aide et on cible les ménages les plus
les plus modestes pour cette transition
en fait et partir surtout du principe
que on va on va le dire on va le dire on
est d'accord c'est que la voiture la
voiture individuelle pour se déplacer en
ville c'est pas le meilleur moyen c'est
plus long c'est plus cher
ça pollue donc on va se dire que c'est
pas le meilleur moyen mais alors c'est
intéressant
effectivement zone rurale je suis d'une
zone rurale je sais que voilà on a pas
de transport en commun etc par contre
c'est la question de l'aménagement de la
ville c'est comment on repense notre
ville sur des déplacements qui nous
permettront à la fois d'avoir une ville
moins polluée d'aller plus vite et que
ça soit moins coûteux donc ça veut dire
agir sur les transports en commun et là
effectivement il y a énormément à faire
on le sait ils ont parisienne on connaît
on connaît le problème mais on voit
qu'on a c'est des problématiques en
termes de transport en commun sur la
question de la tarification c'est sûr
que si sur les transports en commun je
le vois notamment aussi sur la question
des TER où on a dans beaucoup de régions
des augmentations des tarifs évidemment
qu'il faut retravailler sur la question
tarifaire notamment sur la question
aussi de la gratuité je pense que ça
aussi ce sont des choses qui sont qui
sont importantes et puis il y a comment
effectivement sur une certaine flotte
parce qu'on aura toujours besoin de de
véhicules comment justement on va sur
des flottes qui sont moins polluantes
mais c'est sûr que si l'objectif c'est
de dire que les 40 millions de voitures
et en ville je sais pas combien ça
représente on va les transformer en
voiture électrique on va dire qu'on aura
rien réglé parce qu'on sait aussi que
les véhicules de société
ont une pollution et notamment euh pour
les effets de pour les effets de l'air
que ça soit relié au frein et au disque
de frein notamment sur la pollution liée
au cuivre et des études très fortes qui
ont été faites sur la question sur la
question des pneus alors la vraie
solution c'est juste demande diminuer
l'apocal individuelle je vais vous
redonner la parole les moyens de le
faire et je vais vous la donner tout de
suite aussi sur cette impact social on
peut là on peut la l'appeler comme ça
des élèves mais d'abord une réaction
celle d'Olivier Marleix le député
d'Eure-et-Loir qui est évidemment aussi
président du groupe LR à l'Assemblée
nationale voilà ce qui dit des élèves
un sujet qui m'exaspère au plus haut
point par exemple c'est les ZF les zones
à faible émission le fait que on est
plus droit de rentrer quand on est comme
moi à bouger d'Eure-et-Loir de rentrer
avec une nature au gasoil dans Paris
est-ce que ça va empêcher le
réchauffement de la planète non ce sera
rien c'est un égoïsme de bobo parisien
un égoïsme de bobo parisien voilà ce que
dit Olivier Marley est-ce que c'est une
mesure socialement injuste ça c'est
l'argument qui est systématiquement mis
en avant par les opposants à toutes les
mesures environnementales on a sa
systématiquement d'abord je voudrais
relativiser ce qui a été dit sur le
remplacement du parc automobile à partir
de du 1er janvier 2023 ce sont les
diesels immatriculés avant 2001 qui
deviennent interdits dans les ZF partout
en France dans le Grand Paris ça a été
anticipé et ce sont oui à certains
endroits mais et ce sont les véhicules
donc essence immatriculés avant 2006 et
diesel immatriculé avant 2011 qui sont
interdits donc il s'agit 2025 c'est 14
millions de véhicules c'est là vous êtes
d'accord sur ce je suis d'accord avec ça
mais d'abord
2025 c'est demain ce qu'on ce qu'on
constate c'est que Paris qui avait
commencé plus tôt et plus fort
repousse repousse un peu les repoussent
un peu les délais je serais pas
surprises que les délaiss soient un peu
repoussés également pour l'ensemble de
la France mais à l'armée de cette façon
en disant qu'il s'agit de remplacer tout
le tout le parc par des véhicules
électriques immédiatement ça n'est pas
juste il existe de nombreuses aides
c'est 2035 ce sera la vente des
véhicules neufs uniquement donc ça veut
dire que les véhicules thermiques
pourront continuer de rouler après 2025
et remplacer aujourd'hui à un diesel qui
a plus de 20 ans par un véhicule plus
récent qui consomme moins qui va polluer
moins ça ça n'est pas non plus
complètement aberrant il existe
des mesures sur ça parce qu'on pense
toujours remplacer un véhicule par un
véhicule neuf mais on peut à la fois sur
la question du rétrofit ça veut dire de
changer un véhicule et changer sa
motorisation la métropole demande de
Grenoble travaille beaucoup là-dessus et
justement on fait des appels du pied à
l'état pour pour avancer encore plus
vite sur cette forme avec une thermique
en véhicule électrique mon collègue joël
Labbé au Sénat avait déposé un
abonnement qui avait été voté d'ailleurs
au Sénat qui était assez judicieux c'est
de dire sont des voitures de critères de
3 souvent quand il y a une prime à la
casse c'est véhicules là sont détruits
quand on remplace par un SUV électrique
et de se dire bah on pourrait récupérer
ces véhicules qui sont encore justement
critères 2 et qui pourraient être
utilisés et d'en faire une flotte
régionale sociale qui soit justement
adapté pour les personnes les plus les
plus modestes sous forme de location
c'est un moment qui était passé qui est
dans la loi dans la loi climat au Sénat
qui a été retiré par le gouvernement et
je pense que le gouvernement pourrait
reprendre ses idées alors c'est des
manières d'aller très vite et surtout de
ne pas surconsommer en tout cas sur ce
type de je vais vous donner la parole il
nous reste une demi-heure dans ce débat
et je voudrais entendre Laetitia avec on
va s'arrêter le temps de votre chronique
sur le le risque de crise sociale
peut-être qu'on est dans une
dramatisation vous allez me le dire que
peuvent entraîner ce cette réforme et
cette et c'est des feux est-ce qu'on
peut penser alors on en parle tellement
depuis 3 ans une rivière d'urgence des
gilets jaunes oui on en parle tout le
temps c'est vrai que même pour la
réforme des retraites par exemple ça
peut aussi faire rogerir cette ce
mouvement qui je vous le rappelle a été
très populaire du début jusqu'à la fin
c'est pour ça que l'exécutif en a peur
et ceux qui qui promènent aussi ce genre
de mesure mais par exemple quand on
regarde à Rouen qui a mis en place une
ZF dans le centre-ville et dans 13
communes un de l'agglomération à partir
du 1er septembre il y a déjà eu des
manifestations Thomas donc on voit bien
qu'il y a quand même du côté de la
population un problème d'acceptabilité
de cette mesure pourquoi parce qu'on l'a
dit à l'instant elle favorise les
ménages plutôt plutôt aux revenus élevés
qui peuvent acheter des voitures neuves
qui peuvent peut-être transformer je ne
sais pas monsieur combien ça coûte de
transformer une voiture ancienne en
voiture électrique m'en face à un coût
et c'est vrai que ceux qui sont
pénalisés sont toujours les couches les
plus voilà les plus basses de la
population et surtout on l'évoquait il
faut proposer des alternatives
évidemment il faut proposer des
alternatives par exemple quand on
regarde Londres parce que c'est
l'exemple qui nous vient en premier
c'est une des villes les premières qui a
interdit son centre-ville aux voitures
il faut pour vous poser des parkings
géants à l'entrée des villes il faut des
transports en commun gratuit pourquoi
pas à Dunkerque ils ont mis en place des
transports en commun gratuit dans le
centre-ville et plus 50% de
fréquentation ça fonctionne mais sans
même aller jusqu'à la gratuité il faut
déjà que le transport en commun
fonctionne oui effectivement on peut le
voir à Paris en ce moment à Paris c'est
une galère totale c'est à dire qu'à
n'importe quelle heure les métros sont
bondés il manque de de conducteurs de
métro bon on ne sait pas si Jean Castex
va régler problème il devrait peut-être
être à la tête de la RATP mais il était
il était entendu par les sénateurs
devant notre émission Paris n'est pas la
France c'est-à-dire monsieur vous l'avez
dit vous venez vous-même d'une d'une une
rurale quand on veut aller travailler en
ville comment faire quand on est encore
une fois un ménage modeste et que il n'y
a pas de transport public digne de ce
nom qu'on ne peut pas aller se
transporter donc c'est vrai que je vous
en parlais en début de mon édito à Rouen
par exemple les premières sanctions vont
être mis en place en mars 2023 donc là
on va voir s'il y aura ou non une
quelque chose voilà une réaction de la
population parce que les 6000 euros de
primes promis par Emmanuel Macron sont
vraiment vécues par la plupart des
Français modestes comme une provocation
6000 euros c'est rien quand la voiture
électrique coûte 30 000 euros
merci Laetitia qui veut réagir il y a
aussi il y a aussi des primes des primes
à la conversion qui sont qui sont du
même ordre de grandeur et des aides
locales alors c'est très très hétérogène
sur l'ensemble de la carte de la France
mais des aides locales qui peuvent être
du même ordre de grandeur donc on
cumulant toutes ces aides cela peut
diminuer fortement le prix le prix
d'achat et puis il n'est pas forcément
nécessaire d'acheter son véhicule
les changements de mode de vie sont
aussi possibles en recourant par exemple
à la location au leasing et là alors il
y a déjà des des compagnies des des
vendeurs de voitures les constructeurs
qui proposent des des mécanismes de
leasing et sinon le gouvernement prévoit
c'est ce qui a été annoncé à plusieurs
reprises un prévoit de mettre en place
un système de leasing à 100 euros par
mois pour les instants les propositions
du gouvernement je voudrais vous
entendre sur les transports en commun
Fabrice go parce que vous vous êtes pas
encore exprimé sur ce sur ce thème là
est-ce que c'est pas un peu l'angle mort
finalement de ce de juste rebondir sur
le fait que là on parle beaucoup de
centre-ville avec les zones de finition
c'est pas du tout le cas là on parle de
métropole et d'agglomération donc quand
on parle par exemple on prend
l'Île-de-France c'est tout ce qu'il y a
à l'intérieur de la 86 donc il faut pas
dire c'est pas seulement le centre-ville
de Paris dans Londres dans Londres c'est
très beaucoup plus large donc ça touche
pas uniquement les parisiens mais les
Franciliens aussi par exemple et ça sera
pareil à Lyon etc etc donc c'est pas
exactement la même chose deuxième chose
pour l'instant par exemple je prends
Paris on a déjà éliminé la vignette 4 et
5 les gens ne se rendent pas de compte
c'est 20% du parc roulant qu'elle
normalement pas le droit de rouler les
gens continuent à rouler se rencontrent
de rien parce que ça pose la question
des sanctions alors ça on va on va venir
et des moyens et des moyens de contrôler
bien sûr par contre je vous garantis que
les jours où les gens vont avoir une
verbalisation automatique quand ils vont
rentrer dans le périmètre là les gens
vont se rendre compte ça va être autre
chose donc sur l'acceptabilité sur le
problème de de transport en commun je
suis complètement d'accord donc on
interdit les gens pour voir parce que
quand on habite à Paris qu'on travaille
dans à Paris pas de problème quand on
fait du parib banlieue tous les jours
c'est pas forcément facile on a besoin
de sa voiture à chaque fois je prends le
cas de Paris mais c'est la même chose
quand on prend Lyon Grenoble ou
Marseille ou toutes les grandes
métropoles et 10 grandes métropoles qui
sont déjà en place mais il faut savoir
une chose quand même c'est que pour
l'instant les transports en commun sont
bondés et puis si on parle de pollution
il va falloir mettre aussi des zones de
finition dans les transports en commun
je rappelle quand même le col CNRS et
respire avec montrer qu'il y avait six
cinq à dix fois plus de particules dans
certaines rames de métro et de RER donc
quand on y passe deux heures par jour
c'est pas très bon au pied au niveau
sanitaire donc est-ce qu'on va mettre
des zones d'effet mission sinon les
transports en commun
est-ce que vous venez de vous venez
d'expliquer c'est qu'on est bien
d'accord c'est à dire que l'orientation
il faut qu'on diminue l'impact et la
place de la voiture et donc sur les sur
les zones rurales moi je trouve que
c'est pareil on a des solutions il faut
pas dire que c'est
moi je peux je peux vous donner des des
exemples vous savez une famille qui a de
voir trois voitures parce que en zone
rurale quand on doit emmener les enfants
etc bah des fois c'est deux trois
voitures une voiture en moyenne c'est
6000 € par mois par an pardon de coups
c'est pas rien enfin j'ai en terme de en
termes de pouvoir d'achat et de
possibilités qu'on pourrait faire je
peux vous dire qu'une famille quand elle
arrive avoir des solutions pour se
séparer d'une voiture voir de deux
plutôt contente parce que c'est 6 voir
12000 euros qui reviennent pour faire
autre chose et bah ça il y a des
possibilités il y a évidemment les
transports en commun et notamment la
question des TER c'est sûr qu'on est et
ça je vous je suis d'accord avec vous
moi je me suis battu pour une ligne de
chemin de fer battue alors que on peut
se dire que c'était évident 50 km pour
aller de Grenoble dans une zone rurale
et voilà on voulait fermer cette ligne
bah heureusement on a on s'est battu
aujourd'hui elle fonctionne elle demande
à cette améliorée la question de
l'autopartage dire de mettre à
disposition dans des villages une
voiture qui soit partagée par la
population
ça existe ça fonctionne ça un coup oui
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
effectivement l'investissement il fait
un accompagnement de l'État et ça
suppose que les collectivités locales
facilitent l'autopartage en fait moi je
voudrais juste dire c'est qu'en fait la
question du de la c'est comment on va
beaucoup plus vite pour amorcer
justement ces changements et évidemment
il faut de l'argent il faut investir il
faut un soutien de l'État moi je me
rappelle Grenoble est la première ZFE et
donc il a été mis en place en 2019 donc
forcément réfléchi 2017 etc Nicolas
Hulot je crois est venu à Grenoble
c'était 2017-2018 donc il était encore
ministre de encore
ministre et je venais d'être de devenir
de devenir sénateur donc je m'en
souviens je m'en souviens très bien quel
était l'appel à la fois d'Eric piolles
maire de Grenoble et de Christophe
Ferrari président de la métropole
c'était de dire mais nous on est pris on
a tout mais aidez-nous de ne nous les
moyens de pouvoir mettre en place notre
politique et on en est toujours au même
point alors une tribune de Christophe
Ferrari le président de la métropole de
Grenoble qui utilise exactement les
mêmes mots parce que il attend parce
qu'il a moins de moyens
en 5 ans justement le gouvernement et
quand tu as calmé peut nous rejoindre à
bien compris qu'il y avait urgence à
réagir bonsoir oui c'est ça on voit les
les inquiétudes effectivement cette
rentrée et sur deux fronts on va le
comprendre effectivement on a vu ça à
l'intérieur que les sénateurs ont écrit
au gouvernement pour s'inquiéter de la
mise en place de ces ZFE donc dans 43
métropoles d'ici 2025 d'ici 2025 on va
c'était lui communiste Céline Brulin qui
a écrit qu'effectivement changer de
véhicule et financièrement inaccessible
pour de nombreux ménages qui a donc
comme cela une réalité économique à
mettre en place des feux mais au
contraire on voit d'autres élus comme
vous monsieur comptable qui écrivent au
gouvernement pour s'inquiéter du fait
qu'il y a aucun moyen déployé pour
appliquer la loi et pour faire respecter
la loi Bernard jaumier et lui parisien a
ainsi écrit au gouvernement le nombre de
contrôle physique est en très faible est
apparu impératif de mettre en place
rapidement la vidéo verbalisation prévue
depuis 2019 ce système devait être
opérationnel en 2021 pour la ZF du Grand
Paris et il écrit par manque de moyens
administratif et financier à louer par
l'État il n'est toujours pas à ce jour à
cette question date il y a quelques
jours on va se mécanisme qui a été
adopté et bien son application elle ne
contente personne alors le gouvernement
n'est pas resté inerte il y a eu des
annonces il y a quelques jours
exactement c'était le 25 octobre dernier
le tout premier comité de suivi des edfe
a été organisé par le ministre de la
transition écologique Christophe Béchu
l'idée était de faire le point sur les
11 métropoles et qui ont déjà mis en
place les ZF et d'en préparer
l'installation donc dans les 32 autres
qu'il avait mise en place d'ici 2025
d'abord et bien en répondant aux
inquiétudes pour les foyers modestes
incapables de changer de véhicule on va
le voir il y a un nouveau bonus
écologique pour la chaîne un véhicule
électrique qui passe à 7000 euros pour
les ménages aux revenus les plus
modestes la prime et la conversion sera
automatiquement renforcée de 1000 euros
lorsque le bénéficiaire le bénéficiaire
habite ou travaille dans une ZFE
troisième annonce qui a eu lieu fin
octobre un plutôt 0 qui sera proposé à
partir du 1er janvier 2023 pour deux en
expérimentation avec pour objectif de
financer l'acquisition d'un véhicule
plus propre sous condition de ressources
écoutez donc le ministre qui savent bien
sûr notre micro est quelques jours
on a lancé hier un groupe de travail
avec tous les maires qui sont concernés
pour qu'au contraire on partage des
questions pour qu'on partage des
inquiétudes dans les inquiétudes il y a
la question sociale celle de
l'accessibilité comment on fait pour que
les plus pauvres qui se retrouvent
parfois avec que les voitures les plus
vieilles précisément ils soient pas
exclus parce que le centre-ville c'est
l'hôpital c'est parfois les services
publics donc toute la réflexion c'est
comment en termes de qualité de l'air on
protège les Français sans le faire au
détriment des plus fragiles donc le
gouvernement Thomas a aussi répondu aux
élus qui s'inquiètent de voir que la loi
n'est pas appliquée y compris là où les
adefe sont déjà créés le ministre a dit
vouloir y aller de façon déterminée avec
là encore des annonces regardez la mise
en place progressive d'un contrôle de
sanctions automatisée à la mi 2024 qui
permettra une mise en oeuvre effective
des edfe et 150 millions d'euros de fond
vert pour financer les études d'analyse
préalable d'évaluation ou encore des
infrastructures pour les collectivités
locales qui vont d'ailleurs un garder
toute l'attitude pour décider du
calendrier c'est collectivités locales
et des périmètres des restrictions mais
donc à un calendrier progressif
d'interdiction de circulation et bien
prévu pour les villes qui dépassent les
seuils européens de qualité de l'air
merci Quentin pour tous ces détails
Mireille sur le insoline la question du
de la sanction il faut bien la poser
parce que là aujourd'hui il y a déjà des
villes qui ont mis en place des et les
feux mais de fait il y a pas de sanction
oui et c'est toujours le problème
lorsqu'il est possible de tricher par
rapport à une régulation
c'est possible c'est possible donc ça
veut dire quoi il faut quoi il faut
équiper de caméra de de surveillance
s'il faut un système automatisé pour que
ça fonctionne on va pas mettre un
policier à chaque entrée de de ville
pour les places
un système très proche dans un certain
nombre de villes par exemple les villes
italiennes ce ne sont pas des des ZF et
ce sont des ATL c'est à dire des zones à
trafic limité et là il y a à l'entrée de
ces zones alors c'est pour d'autres
raisons en fait que ça a été mis en
place dans ces villes italiennes c'est
pour limiter la congestion et donc la
circulation est limitée aux résidents
aux résidents de la zone et ce sont
surtout les touristes et les visiteurs
occasionnels qui sont qui sont écartés
et à l'entrée de chaque zone ainsi qu'à
la sortie il y a des caméras et la
verbalisation est automatique je peux
vous le garantir et donc pour l'instant
ça n'existe pas en France on est bien on
est bien d'accord Fabrice Go Sport
là que la prise de conscience de ce que
sont les et des feux se fera le
technologiquement le moyen il est assez
simple
et mis en place en 2022 ça a été
repoussé d'abord en 2023 et maintenant
nous annonce 2024 et l'argument c'était
justement un fait technologique à
l'origine mais bon moi je pense que
c'est surtout que on a un petit peu peur
d'y aller parce que ça va être difficile
de en plus de ça tout ça cumule quand
même pour les automobilistes quand même
parce que les automobilistes ils ont les
zones de famille ils ont les
augmentations sur le prix du carburant
et d'ailleurs je rappelle que là la
remise va descendre à partir de du 15 je
vous garantis que ça allait faire une
surprise quand vous allez voir que le
prix du baril va augmenter est en train
d'augmenter actuellement on a un malus
qui tous les ans se renforcent quand on
achète un véhicule parce qu'on parle de
renouvellement de parc et de pouvoir
acheter un nouveau véhicule je sais pas
si vous avez remarqué le prix des
véhicules a largement augmenté de subi
ces dernières années et derrière le
marché de l'automobile le marché de
l'automobile a largement augmenté oui
mais ça ils ont augmenté pourquoi les
véhicules la taille des véhicules mais
ça c'est normal ça en Europe on nous met
des options de sécurité des options de
confort et des options de pollution ça
vous a pas marqué qu'actuellement
maintenant il faut de plus en plus de
filtres à particules il faut par exemple
électrifier son véhicule donc on a une
double technologie on a un moteur
thermique
une batterie électrique donc forcément
la taille des véhicules augmente donc de
dire oui les véhicules augmentent c'est
des SUV il faut les interdire il y a
aussi des raisons technologiques qui
fait que le véhicule grossit et ça leur
dit bien sûr que alors un véhicule
électrique est d'ailleurs beaucoup plus
lourd et vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs le
rapport de la dame ou maintenant plus de
la moitié des particules ne viennent
plus de l'échappement donc ça veut dire
des technologies on a avancé
physiquement enterré à faire
pause et notamment la question la
question centrale et on va y venir de la
place de la voiture dans nos dans nos
villes c'est vraiment ça qui est au cœur
de de ce débat j'aurais donné un exemple
étranger vous avez cité on a parlé de de
l'Italie on a parlé de Londres et
également à Londres pour accéder au
centre de la capital les automobilistes
doivent payer 15 livres depuis 2019 les
véhicules les plus polluants qui
circulent malgré l'interdiction dans
cette zone qui est appelée ultra faible
émission doivent payer une amende et il
y a eu un parlait de santé publique ça a
été les premiers arguments qu'on a donné
dans ce dans ce débat la quantité de
particules fines
à Londres elle a baissé de près de 20%
par rapport à 2016 le chiffre qui est
donné c'est un chiffre de
-19% alors j'ai pas le montant en
parlant de en livre de de l'amende mais
je trouve que c'est quand même très
intéressant de voir l'exemple de l'effet
alors qui s'est mis en place en 2019 sur
les véhicules utilitaires et sur les
poids lourds donc dans un premier temps
donc il y a déjà des amendes alors c'est
vrai que d'ailleurs les présidents de
métropoles demandent quoi justement que
soit mis en place les systèmes
automatiques c'est c'est eux qui le
demandent pourquoi on est tellement ça
parce que là on voit que ça marche pas
de Grenoble qui était la cuvette et la
configuration une métropole très polluée
on a des résultats et des résultats très
très intéressants puisque là on essayait
on est passé en dessous justement des
critères d'accord on a besoin de la
question vous allez nous dire c'est
parce que le gouvernement a pas
développé les moyens est-ce que c'est
pas aussi parce que les élus on manquait
un peu de courage politique en allant
jusqu'au sanctions des populations si je
reprends évidemment il faut du courage
politique ça ça je pense moi ce que
j'entends plus tôt c'est plutôt des
présidents de de métropole qui qui sont
plutôt qui demandent qui demandent à
avancer qui mettent en place ces choses
là mais qui demande vraiment un soutien
et un appui de l'État et c'est sûr que
sur des gros infrastructures sur des
transports en commun on verra j'ai
entendu le ministre là parlait parlé
dans dans votre dans votre partage on
verra on va avoir le projet de loi de
finance on va voir tous les ans auprès
de loi de finances on met un amendement
pour la TVA 5,5 sur les transports en
commun qui est voté d'ailleurs souvent
au Sénat on verra si le gouvernement
s'il sera voté puis si le gouvernement
le laissera ou s'il le rejettera on a eu
un plan de 3 milliards justement pour le
train du quotidien qui a été voté à
l'Assemblée nationale si je crois qu'il
a pas été retenu dans dans le cadre du
49-3 donc on a besoin de politique forte
et je dirais que c'est pas c'est pas de
l'argent mis en l'air puisque c'est à la
fois sur justement envers les plus
défavorisés parce que c'est c'est leur
patrimoine et c'est ça leur permet
justement de se déplacer et puis ça a un
effet sanitaire qui indéniable donc oui
on peut y aller mais oui ça veut dire
qu'il faut une vraie volonté politique
de l'État alors les inquiétudes qui
s'expriment dans les métaux proboles qui
doivent créer ces défauts on en a parlé
c'est avant janvier 2025 je rappelle
mais comment ça se passe là on est on
est dans les dans les dans les idées
dans le débat mais je voudrais qu'on
passe à l'image maintenant comment ça se
passe dans les villes qui l'ont déjà
adopté on a choisi l'exemple de Toulouse
Toulouse ou les voitures avec crit
vignette critères pardon 4 et 5 seront
interdits dès le mois de janvier
reportage signé Cécile Sixou
des bolide étincelant et pourtant pas si
récent ces motards toulousain les
possèdent parfois depuis plus de 20 ans
s'ils peuvent aujourd'hui rouler sur la
rocade à partir du 1er janvier 2023 ils
n'auront plus cette liberté leur moto
trop polluantes seront interdites dans
la zone à faible émission La ZFE autour
et dans le centre de la ville rose
aujourd'hui tu n'as plus le droit de
rouler à Toulouse comme tu peux rouler
par exemple dans d'autres villes qui
n'ont pas encore mis en place le fait
d'effet c'est-à-dire que si tu passes
sur la rocade potentiellement tu peux te
faire arrêter et on peut t'expliquer que
en fait il faut que tu fasses le tour de
Toulouse voilà et que tu as avec ta
bécane t'as pas le droit c'est motards
ne sont pas les seuls à anticiper le
passage en zone faible émission dans
cette usine de production laitière
située dans Toulouse intra-muros Jérôme
Servière le chef d'entreprise s'inquiète
déjà de l'état des voitures de ces
salariés et de leur vignettes
voilà bon ben ils ont pas de vignette
encore
si critères 3 lui sera concerné il sera
concerné au 1er janvier 2024 Jérôme
Servière a mené une étude auprès de ses
230 employés ce qui possède une vignette
critère 4 ne pourront plus venir
travailler en voiture dès le premier
janvier 2023 et les critères 3 seront
concernés début 2024
décalés donc la voiture est le seul
moyen de transport possible pour tous
les salariés qui sont en équipe et ce
qui est préoccupant c'est que au 1er
janvier 2024 on a quasiment les deux
tiers de nos effectifs en production en
équipe qui s'y ne se passe rien ne
seront plus en mesure de venir
travailler il souhaite mettre en place
une application de covoiturage et
installé des vélos en libre-service mais
c'est que cela ne sera pas suffisant
la piste
de demander aux salariés de gérer la
situation elle nous paraît assez
assez difficile à mettre en oeuvre parce
que tout simplement même avec un bonus
une voiture électrique c'est un an et
demi de salaire pour pour nos salariés
c'est c'est pas envisageable pour la
majorité d'entre eux donc nous ce qu'on
demande c'est de la concertation voilà
on est une entreprise une fois de plus
site web et responsable donc on prendra
nos responsabilités mais il est clair
que tout seul on y arrivera pas de la
concertation car à partir du deuxième
semestre de 2024 ce qui nous
respecteront pas la loi auront des
amendes pour le patron du Medef de
Haute-Garonne le gouvernement impose au
chef d'entreprise une évolution à marche
forcée et pour le moment ils ont encore
trompé d'informations on a l'impression
que personne ne sait ce que c'est que la
ZFE donc il y a un élément d'information
qui manque un peu à l'appel et y compris
nos entreprises c'est-à-dire que les
salariés les chefs d'entreprise quel que
soit leur taille à moins d'être impliqué
et engagé dans une association ou un
syndicat patronal ou salarié aujourd'hui
on ne sait pas ce que c'est que la
preuve même qu'on n'est pas prêt après
la métropole de Toulouse en charge
d'appliquer la loi sur le territoire
propose d'ici 2024 de mettre en place un
guichet unique pour les aides au
changement de véhicule et d'adapter au
maximum les règles de dérogation de la
ZFE
on a grosso modo un an et demi pour
corriger les problèmes et faire en sorte
que les et des feux soient sur des
modalités meilleures pour les gens et
notamment pour ne pas sanctionner les
plus modestes quand je dis les plus
modestes c'est évidemment les personnes
les ménages mais aussi les petits
artisans les petits entrepreneurs qui
ont des véhicules utilitaires parfois un
petit peu anciennes le maire de Toulouse
souhaite que l'État double ses aides
pour les plus modestes une manière
d'éviter que l'écologie ne s'oppose une
nouvelle fois à l'économie
Fabrice autrefois nos vies elles ont été
pensés aménager depuis presque un siècle
autour de la voiture et pas si simple de
revenir en arrière c'est ça alors
imaginez ce que vous pensez il y a quand
même 40 millions d'autobus sur 67
millions de Français quand même donc
c'est sûr que évidemment l'automobile
est très important et aujourd'hui je
trouve franchement il faut quand même
être honnête je pense que personne peut
me dire le contraire les automobilistes
ont quand même le dollars surtout on
parle de pollution on parle de et à
chaque fois si l'automobile vous rendez
compte que tout ce qu'on est en train de
cumuler sur les automobilistes les aider
feux les malus renforcés les taxes sur
les carburants tous les jours on a
l'impression qu'il y a quelque chose qui
va nous tomber sur le coin du de du du
de la tête mais j'allais dire de du bref
de la voiture du portefeuille
portefeuille c'est un peu insupportable
quand même et c'est vrai qu'en plus de
ça quand on parle des vignettes critères
il faut quand même se rappeler qu'elles
sont sorties en 2016 sur un état des
lieux en 2015 depuis des évolutions de
normes et il y a des paradoxes qui sont
je veux juste vous appuyer sur un
paradoxe qui est fera quand même
m'expliquer comment c'est même possible
vous parliez tout à l'heure des primes à
la reconversion et vous avez
complètement raison on a eu des primes
alors recommandations qui ont été
efficace un moment la leçon beaucoup
moins on a eu le droit jusqu'en juin
2021 à une prime à la reconversion pour
acheter un véhicule diesel vinaigre
critère 2 récent rendez compte jusqu'en
juin 2021 à Paris
2024 Paris 8 diesel et puis de Vignac
il y aura deux ans avec une tu auras
deux ans et qui devrait la laisser c'est
ça il faut la mettre à la poubelle
franchement tout le monde va d'accord
pour dire que ça c'est absurde
ça a été fait sous la pression du
secteur automobile et des associations
d'automobilistes pour pour justement
permettre à ceux qui ne souhaitaient pas
changer de quasiment rien changer alors
l'industrie auto qui voulait qui avait à
qui on avait dit produisait des diesels
pendant des années qui en avait beaucoup
à vendre on a favorisé effectivement la
production du diesel mais depuis 20 ans
on signale que fiscalité du diesel était
ultra avantageuse donc ça c'est une
incitation étatique absolument mais
depuis 20 ans tout le monde tous les
tous les scientifiques tous les
économistes de l'environnement alerté
sur le fait que ça n'était pas tenable
et qu'il fallait absolument revenir
là-dessus et les industriels faisaient
mine de ne pas s'en soucier
faisait de la recherche sur des pauses
d'échappement qui permettraient des
filtres à particules qui permettraient
de filtrer les particules au lieu de
faire de la recherche recherche sur des
véhicules électriques et c'est seulement
depuis que la politique est beaucoup
plus volontariste dans ce dans ce
domaine que véritablement le secteur du
véhicule électrique a décollé et
pourquoi l'industrie française est-elle
en retard sur l'industrie chinoise et
pourquoi est-on obligé d'attendre la
mise en place du leasing du leasing à
100 € que on est obligé d'attendre que
les industriels français soient en
mesure de mettre de mettre à disposition
des consommateurs français des véhicules
assemblés en France c'est parce que le
secteur automobile a joué à l'aveugle et
à penser à penser que de réponse
sur l'industrie je peux en parler
effectivement aujourd'hui il faut savoir
que sur les voitures électriques 85 %
des batteries sont fabriquées en Asie
que la chaîne de valeur aujourd'hui les
grands gagnants du véhicule électrique
c'est la Chine parce que ils font non
seulement l'extraction lithium et
cobalts le raffinage alors nous on
commence à en parler mais on a 10 ou 15
une part de responsabilité des
constructeurs français qu'entreprise
virage assez tôt le bonus malus ou le
malus maintenant plus de bonus le malus
il était sur le CO2 et il y a un fait
que le diesel avait un avantage par
rapport à l'essence c'était moins de CO2
donc le bonus malus qui est encore
actuellement en vigueur et plus
favorable au diesel que l'essence allez
avec l'hybride c'est en train de changer
de 5 minutes parce que je dois être on
l'a évoqué finalement tout au long de ce
débat mais je voudrais vraiment terminer
et centrer là-dessus c'est la question
c'est la place de la voiture est-ce
qu'il faut encore des voitures
individuelles dans nos centres vides
j'aurai sur centre-ville vous avez déjà
répondu tout à l'heure mais il faut
aller jusque là ça ira faire c'est un
changement de mentalité on a été élevé
avec la voiture individuelle il faut
l'oublier c'est ce que vous nous dit
c'est pas c'est pas l'oublier c'est pas
aller jusque là c'est juste de se
repositionner de se dire à quoi sert la
voiture parce que j'aime pas le terme
automobiliste on est tous automobilistes
c'est un outil un outil qui sert à se
déplacer est-ce que cet outil qui sert à
se déplacer il est efficace moi c'est ce
qui m'intéresse est-ce que il va me
permettre d'aller beaucoup plus vite
d'un point un point B et ce qui va me
permettre de moins polluer parce que
c'est important pour les enfants qui ont
des bronchiolites pour ceux qui ont de
l'asthme etc est-ce que il va me coûter
plus ou moins cher c'est ça que je vais
regarder dans ce moyen que j'ai pour
aller de ce point et ce point B et je
suis désolé mais aujourd'hui la voiture
individuelle liée au nombre liés
effectivement on a eu des villes qui ont
été construites autour de la voiture on
envoie les limites actuellement c'est le
moyen le plus cher pour se déplacer le
plus coûteux c'est le moyen qu'un impact
en plus sur l'espace de la ville qui est
important on passe 90% de son temps à
trouver une place de voiture quand on a
une place de stationnement donc on voit
bien que c'est un modèle et un moyen qui
ne répond à aucun de ses objectifs alors
qu'on sait que on a plein d'autres
moyens dans une ville pour se déplacer
transport en commun la marche à pied
pour de des distances courtes le vélo
mais il peut y avoir la trottinette
c'est peu peu importe et on le voit et
ce que je trouve intéressant c'est quand
on a une vraie volonté politique je
reprends l'exemple de Grenoble j'étais
lundi justement mais justement avec ma
voiture parce que je fais aussi tout ce
que j'ai pas d'autres moyens
actuellement puisque la ligne de chemin
de fer dont je parlais est en réparation
et ben qu'est-ce que j'ai vu et ben
j'avais jamais vu autant de monde sur
les pistes cyclables parce que je dirais
quel que soit le temps parce que ça y
est c'est quelque chose où tout le monde
a compris je dirais une fois aussi à
Paris mais aussi il y a pas la ville du
coup à travailler là-dessus c'est-à-dire
qu'on est sécurisé qu'on a des données
il y a un mot qu'on a assez peu prononcé
c'est le mot d'usage c'est-à-dire passer
de la possession à l'usage ça c'est
quelque chose qui faut dire dans un
débat sur les les zones affaiblissement
oui absolument parce que c'est pas
obligé d'acheter une voiture tout à fait
lorsque vous dites que nos existences
ont été façonnées par les par la
disponibilité des automobiles et là et
la possibilité de mobilité après tout
cette mobilité ne passe pas forcément
par la possession de d'un véhicule on
peut le partager on peut le louer
uniquement lorsqu'on en a besoin pour
sortir de la ville où on habite quand on
loue comme ça du tout d'abord il arrive
ils sont très chers non non je vous
assure qu'il existe il existe des
systèmes par exemple de location de
particulier à particulier il y a des il
y a des plateformes qui existent qui
permettent ça et par conséquent ça
permet à un possesseur d'automobile de
le partager avec d'autres personnes qui
ne le connaissaient pas le système
d'autopartage moi je suis abonné à un
système qui s'appelle citizen mais voilà
mais
franchement c'est un abonnement annuel
et ensuite ça permet d'utiliser une
voiture une heure deux heures etc avec
des prix donc qui restent quand même
très abordables mais je suis d'accord
aussi alors réfléchi sur la question de
la tarification de la gratuité non mais
il faut qu'on y réfléchisse aussi sur
ces tissures de de dispositifs il y a ce
mot usage je voulais qu'on l'emploi puis
il y a le mot liberté parce que vous
l'avez pas employé mais finalement l'un
des arguments qui est le plus souvent
donné par ceux qui défendent cette
civilisation de l'automobile c'est la
liberté
oui mais en fait le problème c'est qu'on
met toujours la charrue avant les bœufs
c'est à dire que on est en train de dire
il faut se passer de l'automobile
notamment mettre dans les centres-villes
et en même temps on dit le problème
c'est qu'actuellement d'en parler et les
transports en commun sont bondés pendant
les heures de pointe et c'est
extrêmement compliqué et puis la
trottinette élevée ok le problème pour
faire du pari Paris pas de problème
quand on fait du Paris banlie en
trottinette ou en vélo j'aimerais bien
voir donc le souci c'est un peu ça c'est
à dire qu'à un moment allez franchement
c'est quand même compliqué et puis bon
après il y a comme une réalité le mur de
la réalité c'est que regarder même à
part très vite on nous dit qu'elle est
transport en commun quand il y a eu les
pénuries de carburant ça a été une des
régions qui a été le plus touchée il y a
le plus de de de
d'attente dans les stations-service donc
c'est ça montre bien que même dans les
villes où il y a des transports en
commun on a quand même besoin en
Île-de-France de sa voiture allez vous
étiez un peu un contre trois puisque
chacun s'est exprime au début donc je
vous ai laissé le dernier mot vous
améliorer qu'il faut merci beaucoup
il y a encore un grand chant et c'était
passionnant de participer enfin de vous
écouter
votre expertise partager avec nos
téléspectateurs merci à tous je vous dis
à demain évidemment 18h-22 heures sur
public Senna et puis votre prochain
rendez-vous politique sur notre antenne
Stéphane Le folle le maire du mansia
ministre de l'Agriculture ce sera
l'invité Dorian Mancini dans bonjour
chez vous belle soirée à toutes et à
tous
[Musique]